yeah I've never spent so much time with
so many different women and when I
started online dating you know maybe
like the swap and the drugs or like you
know women but I was just dating women
life isn't as much as I was doing drugs
in the past you know just before I went
into rehab I was taking heroin you know
I was using heroin everyday and stuff
like that you know and I ain't addicted
to ice before that so you know I didn't
want to go out and score drugs and then
[__] up all that hard work that I'd done
to to get clean and to get my life back
on track you know so I started online
dating you know I would be chatting to
as many as 50 girls at a time you know
for me I become like addicted to
informations because of the sheer
numbers you have I would say on average
I was meeting about three girls a week
and like a lot of the people that are
mentoring me through life recovery and
stuff Wilhelm negative on what I was
doing because all I was doing was you
know in their eyes were swapping drugs
for women and stuff this one was a
little bit different just because she
she look like she should be on her side
she was really beautiful she mentioned
about my glasses
Oxana my own glasses she was basically
into being very flirtatious Lee like she
like a geeky thing so yeah I thought you
know this girl was for sure but you know
well sweet of them hit the jackpot you
know
at that time my wife I happen to be
doing some new you think I was reading
The Game of Thrones books you know which
Massey you know I'm knockin on never
really read before and stuff you know
which again I think made her think that
I was um some real nerd anyway I played
it I played up to it you know I thought
oh sweet if this it's gonna keep these
girl chatting to me no worries I'll work
that angle you know she was the one
being very forward she was like oh would
you like to see you know photos of me
naked and all these sort of stuff when
girls are doing that you want to make
sure that it's name you know you don't
want it to be some fat dude or just you
know getting off on your penis
so she eventually invited me over to her
house like to have sex with her she was
said what are you doing I'm horny why
don't you come over and I did I went
over there she was like in lingerie when
she opened the door you know so yeah
like she played it up
[Music]
[Applause]
you know we hung out seem to be all cool
and stuff but I left there I thought I
was on top of the world I saw it fall
off come getting better you know at
least amazingly hot chick that you know
he's turned on by me when I got home
later that day she'd asked me Facebook
friends with me and I didn't really
think anything of it at a time yeah
whatever couldn't hurt
so what she had done she actually
recorded us seven six I could tell she
had recorded me from a computer you can
barely see her you can see me writing it
doggystyle I've got a really distinctive
tattoo on my shoulder like so and you
can see my face you can definitely tell
100% it's me she sent me a whole list of
names that I was friends with in
Facebook she said she was gonna send
this video to all these people that were
in the friends list
Easy's once heard a phone that were
people with my Serna and you know i said
you have my sisters
and I was like [__] she wanted $5,000
you know otherwise she wasn't gonna send
this video it's a today's paper and
Wireless it woulda brought me what's the
embarrassment for all the other people
it was just more sisters I did not want
freaking sisters to have to go through
that you know when you're a drug addict
you put your family through hell you
know and what at that stage I've been
clean for probably about you know six
months you know I'm doing really well
that's the last thing I wanna do is to
have to have my sister's know that home
getting up to this sort of stuff my mum
would just say you deserve it so
basically I said to her yeah I'll get
you the money and I've had no intention
of getting of the $5,000 but all I
wanted to do was to get that computer
you know all I did was like Google
picture you know and money and just
showed her picture of $50 no it's like
you know I've got the cash can I come
over and I said but like a cheese we
have to have sex again [__] I don't want
you to be naked
[Music]
that first she wanted to know where the
money was you know I had like a little s
almost little man versus you know like a
night I had luck about five hundred
dollars for cashing it and I just showed
her the top she still was enticing it
was sex at that stage this time you know
I've got no interesting I'm having sex
with her you know all I wanted to do was
get that laptop and get out of there
I had a real goer I said you can't go
doing this to paperwork I told her
straight up I said we'll come honestly
because you think I am you know I showed
her my track marks I said we'll come in
shooting drugs for three years there's
an old saying you can't [__] a
bullshitter and I said girl keeps just
running to the wrong person so I think
she's starting to get worried you know I
think she's starting to realize that I'm
not before sure about that she's um
taking me for
all I did was get that computer so as
soon as I had I just basically sexy yeah
I mean yeah she she couldn't follow me
because she was naked you know I'd asked
for it's been naked I'd already thought
of that because I was like you know once
I get it outside she won't chase me
- understanding the most rate and I went
and just chucked off the end of the pier
[Music]
Tamia it was like anything in life you
know I had all sometimes and I had [__]
times and I met so many different people
which had never done before yeah by the
end of it I was looking more for a
girlfriend you know it was enough you
know it worked it was surely enough
you
tinder is a great game it's like the
Pope's needs but with people I love you
to the best game until I hate you but
not a good game it's a double-edged
sword
[Music]
I think I'd only just started dating
again after sometime and was you know I
had no idea I was doing like oh I didn't
have any kind of good radar of what men
wanted from me
you know if they wanted to sleep
together I just kind of was saying yes
because they said G Amano and I was like
oh not really but are we okay I was
honestly thinking about my surrealist I
was an empty black hole and giant void
where emotions should have been and I
was really sad about that it's like I'm
never gonna be whole again
and so I decided to do six months of
celibacy just take it out of the
equation I was like well I still go on
dates and that'll be really good I just
check out the sex bit for a bit six
months was loosely based on the end of
the year and so New Year's Eve was gonna
be my last time and honestly was
surprisingly easy
[Music]
I'm at the fireman it's like hello
fireman hello
for kind of pictures do you get in your
head when you imagine a hot fireman ujin
you know the overalls and probably
nothing under the overalls and the hose
delicious dusty for photos and because I
was still a bit of a tender baby I
didn't get that dick pics were like so
common I'm gonna send you a photo of my
juicy [__] what I'd watch whoa I was not
prepared for that and so I think she
kind of waned me a little bit into
sending like sexy pics mine or always
very tasteful by the way I was like you
know an arty magazine model eventually
fireman I decided to meet up he got out
of his car I don't think I knew how tall
he was at that point and he unfolded all
six foot three broad shouldered nests of
his fireman self he was a golden God he
was so handsome I audibly gasped I was
like oh my god and he paid and I was
like oh he's dreamy
and we walked back to our cars and he
scooped me up in the middle of the
footpath kissed me so my feet weren't
even touching the ground and I wrapped
my hands around his waist and like oh my
gosh people could have seen he's like I
don't care
kiss me more golden God fireman
[Music]
we'd had a couple of meetups and he was
being super look at me I could be the
best husband material in the world
saying all the right things
I was totally smitten so when he was
going with Christmas because it was
ended a year I was going to his parents
in the country while he was away he
messaged me every single day all day
long
causing me babe and beautiful and all of
the wonderful things that make you melt
on the inside came back to Melbourne
after Christmas holidays it also
happened to be New Year's Eve and he
came over and was like what have you
done
his eyes were really red and so I'm like
God you've been through the balls what's
wrong with your eyes as I go I got hay
in them like oh of course you did get
hay in your eyes mom and pop Australia's
farm and I was like our baby we kissed
and hugged and it was all so romantic
and we would give each other massages on
my bed
and so it all gets a bit heated
I've got to explain why I'm not doing
this and so I was like okay look I'm
doing six months of celibacy and in fact
it ends tomorrow just one more day can
you hang up one more day and he was like
okay it's important to you I can wait
and I was like ah he's even better so we
had our separate knees eve parties to go
shoot and then we'd made up a bit later
perhaps
[Applause]
two days after New Year's and I hadn't
heard from him and that was very odd
eventually he's like hey sorry I just
wanted to let you know that I hooked up
with a girl on New Year's and we've been
spending heaps of time together so I
thought it was fair that I should tell
you like heaps of time together what
heaps of time together like 48 hours
suddenly heaps of time together I was
like hang on a second you were at my
house on the afternoon of New Year's Eve
it's like are you kidding me it's
devastated
and about a week later I got a really
sore eye I was like I think I've been a
guard to the hospital this is not good
and they took one look at me and they
just went you've got a really terrible
case of viral bacterial conjunctivitis
like oh it's really highly contagious
have you seen anyone recently who's had
arrived he had conjunctivitis sure
that's not so bad you think it lasted
for three months rough work I look like
I'd had a stroke my face dropped on one
side the most excruciating ly painful
thing I've ever been through and I have
permanent scarring on my cornea from it
I was just like you scummy fireman
sex-crazed dickbag all I got for dating
apps was a really bad eye infection and
permanent scarring hate you gender I
hate you
[Music]
you